La diabetes tipo 1 es una condición en la
cual su páncreas no produce insulina, una
hormona que el cuerpo necesita para mantener
los niveles apropiados de azúcar en la sangre.
Después que usted come alimentos que contienen
hidratos de carbono, los productos químicos
en el intestino delgado los descomponen en
moléculas de azúcar simple llamadas glucosa.
Luego, las células que recubren el intestino
delgado absorben la glucosa, la cual pasa
al torrente sanguíneo.
Cuando la sangre llega al páncreas, las células
beta del páncreas detectan el incremento
de los niveles de glucosa.
Las células beta liberan insulina en el torrente
sanguíneo para reducir los niveles de glucosa
y para mantener la glucosa sanguínea en un
nivel saludable.
La mayoría de las células del cuerpo tienen
ciertos receptores en su superficie que se
unen a la insulina circulante.
La insulina actúa como la llave de una cerradura
para abrir la célula, de tal manera que la
glucosa circulante puede ingresar a dicha
célula.
Ahora sus células pueden utilizar la glucosa
para producir la energía que necesitan para
funcionar correctamente.
Si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1, las células
beta del páncreas pierden su capacidad de
producir insulina, dando como resultado altos
niveles de glucosa en la sangre y otras complicaciones.
En la diabetes tipo 1, su sistema inmunológico
-específicamente sus glóbulos blancos- consideran
a las células beta pancreáticas como si
fueran cuerpos extraños.
En una respuesta autoinmune, sus glóbulos
blancos segregan anticuerpos que destruyen
a sus propias células beta.
Como resultado, el páncreas produce poca
o ninguna insulina.
Sin la insulina, la glucosa no puede ingresar
a sus células; dichas células están desnutridas
debido a la falta de las calorías que deberían
recibir de la glucosa.
Además, el nivel de glucosa se acumula en
el torrente sanguíneo, dando lugar a una
condición llamada hiperglucemia.
Los síntomas más comunes de la hiperglucemia
en la diabetes tipo 1 son: excesiva hambre
y sed, necesidad de orinar frecuentemente,
pérdida de peso inexplicable,
fatiga, debilidad, irritabilidad y visión
borrosa.
Si la hiperglucemia no se trata, usted puede
enfermarse gravemente.
Debido a que usted no tiene suficiente insulina
en la sangre, las células no pueden utilizar
la glucosa para obtener energía.
Como resultado, su cuerpo descompone las reservas
de grasa y de proteínas como fuente alternativa
de energía.
A medida que la descomposición de la grasa
continúa, ciertos subproductos conocidos
como cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan en la
sangre, dando lugar a una condición llamada
cetosis.
Cuando los cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan
a niveles peligrosamente altos, se produce
una condición llamada cetoacidosis diabética,
que puede poner en peligro la vida.
Si sus niveles de glucosa en sangre siguen
siendo altos en el tiempo, se pueden producir
problemas de salud a largo plazo, tales como
la aterosclerosis, ceguera, daño a los nervios
y enfermedad renal.
Si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 1, su meta
es mantener su glucosa en sangre dentro de
los niveles normales.
Esto se realiza a través de una combinación
adecuada de reemplazo de la insulina,
monitoreo de la glucosa en sangre y, de igual
importancia, seguir una dieta saludable y
hacer ejercicios de forma regular.
Debido a que su páncreas deja de producir
insulina, usted deberá administrarse insulina
para reemplazar la que su cuerpo debería
producir.
Un profesional médico autorizado puede entrenarlo
para que usted se inyecte la insulina de manera
subcutánea.
Usted deberá administrarse varias inyecciones
al día, rotando el punto de aplicación para
evitar daños en los tejidos y problemas de
absorción.
Otra forma de administrarse la insulina es
a través de una bomba de insulina, la cual
está adherida a su cuerpo y le administra
la insulina a través de un tubo que está
implantado bajo su piel.
Usted tendrá que revisar el nivel de glucosa
en la sangre varias veces al día con un glucómetro.
Para ello, debe pinchar su dedo con una aguja
pequeña llamada lanceta y colocar una gota
de sangre en el glucómetro.
Conocer su nivel de glucosa en la sangre le
permite ajustar su dosis de insulina, las
calorías que usted come durante las comidas
y la actividad física que realice.
Usted deberá seguir una dieta saludable y
realizar ejercicios de forma regular para
controlar su nivel de glucosa y reducir el
riesgo de sufrir enfermedades cardiovasculares.